[Music]
it's overnight hours it's over 90 what
is up everybody its Anna Mac and this
gods and I know how name yeah it'll go
then and welcome to this special video
really special videos to celebrate the
fact that our subscribers are over 9000
everyone that is crazy that is seriously
crazy we want to make this quick video
to thank everybody we appreciate it so
much and like when you think about it
when you think about over nine thousand
subscribers that is a big number because
you know some youtubers have like
millions of subscribers so then they say
oh yeah I have a million you only have
two hundred thousand that's nothing bro
but these are not just numbers these are
real people who actually like your
content this was more than most
universities have like students enrolled
yeah like it's people actually enjoy
your content and you want to see more of
your content and that's a huge I'm like
you imagine walking down the street and
seeing over 9000 people like you would
be like what is going on is a revolution
going on it is or is it an uproar anime
uproar I will double the corny but let's
just move on yeah so we just want to
make this quick video to really thank
everybody for all your support the
community would built I think is the
biggest thing in dealing say the
community doesn't be built we actually
made friends who are active right on the
channel supporting us on the discord on
social media in the comments in the
channel it's been crazy go then say
something smart and entertaining thank
you guys and I appreciate everyone who
recognizes that goes that is better than
Adam back good job as yeah so that was a
good joke that was not great but that
was a good joke thanks goes and I said I
said you should be entertaining and you
did it well yeah so we want to give
everyone a quick shout out again and we
want to say that we're going to be so
we're announcing we're going to be
making a special video for over 10,000
so once we reach that big ten can live
digits guys the five on extra digit
growth on the next slide you crazy we're
going to be making a special video a Q&A
video where we're going to be answering
your
question 2 if you have questions for us
leave them in the comments to this video
and we will then answer it answer it in
the next video and make sure to make
them good and entertaining because we
want to make it a fun time I've got
questions I know you guys can do it are
we going to be drunk answering questions
I don't know no one knows will sadly
after I centers Teachers College of me
another thing another thing we would
like you guys to actually send us your
art so we notice in the discord and
there's a lot of you are very talented
who make art artistic drawings of anime
as tough it out so we want you to send
us your art you can send to us through
the discord just private message anime
uproar or you can send it to us at anime
of the email anime / @ gmail.com
basically it can be fan art of the two
of us anything related how it is like
animated anything related to anime
uproar and or it can just be something
you're proud of some art work that
you've done so what we want to do is
while we're reading your questions and
answering that we want to showcase some
of your art so basically send us your
art send us your deviant art link or
whatever and we will have those in the
description to kind of help showcase
some of your talents because you guys
are awesome and like all in this court
I've seen a lot of fun stuff and I'm
really impressed so yeah we just wanted
to kind of help you guys out showcase
you and yeah just make the video more
entertaining right of course and we got
a lot of cool stuff on the way and for
around the ten thousand mark we're
taking as rewarding our most passionate
subscribers and most committed
subscribers with merchandise and we're
going to have merchandise available for
everyone yes what we're going to do is
we're working on getting some
merchandise and una giveaway like shirt
stuff we got anime out / related for
some of most committed supporters we're
still trying to figure out the logistics
though cos you know making the shirt is
one thing but sending them to all over
the world the Philippines Australia
China Latin America that's a little hard
logistically but we are going to work on
that and we will keep you posted and
also if you have ideas for designs for
shirts so if you're an artist and you
have an idea for what how you would like
an anime up for sure to look we would
love to see those as well so feel free
to send out and lastly be sure to follow
us on Twitter are going to set up a
Twitter account and we're going to be
playing games on there as well we're
going to happy streaming there so follow
us on twitter link is in the description
and
so be sure to do that because we're
going to be streaming games like
undertale brawl holla and just like cool
anime and maybe some not so anime
related games and maybe even some cards
against humanity online stuff with a
bunch of you guys playing with us we're
not living we'll figure it out guys we
have a whole bunch of other social media
so make sure to follow our Facebook
Twitter Instagram as well we'll put all
that in the description as well yeah and
that's very important follow us on
twitter facebook instagram because you
never know when something could be some
technical difficulties with youtube and
then you so you can hear from us daily
if something's going on same thing with
discord discord what's having issues
there last week so again follow us on
social media so you can be in touch we
can always tell you that something's
going on if there's any issue we can
stay in touch the whole time and of
course discord link is also in the
description we've a lot of cool stuff
going on a discord every day and a safe
he's never there goes that his never say
I make the rare appearance but prepare
your master vols people yeah yeah he's
like he is the rare Pokemon there
however I'm there I'm always hanging out
we do cut okay we do fan fictions we do
daily pull just like really really fun
stuff great community move established
and yeah I'll definitely be there more
frequently a sort of lapse of time from
school girl you don't know for sure you
will ya however yeah that's nice I think
all we want to say and again thank you
guys so much this is create one more
thing well worth a make sure if you want
you can also send us messages to or
questions like we said via Twitter and
via Facebook as well we'll be using
those as well as well as YouTube yes so
feel free to do that we check everything
daily so leave your questions here in
the comments or on social media thank
you again for making this community so
awesome and say oh what a great
community I got don't be a wee because
I'm up any live with our stop they go go
away still be paid beef o me we all
forgot until next time see a space
cowboy swag
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]